at the first Academy Awards ceremony
Janet Gaynor won the Best Actress Award
for her work and not one but three films
that's the way they did it back in 1927
this year as in the past six decades the
five gifted women nominated for this
honor have been chosen by their peers
for one great performance in one film
and they are from Camille Cordell
Isabelle Adjani Oh dates from Shirley
Valentine Pauline colors from music
barking - Jessica Lange and from the
Fabulous Baker boys Michelle Pfeiffer
from Driving Miss Daisy Jessica Tandy
and the Oscar goes to Jessica Tandy
I never expected in a million years that
I would ever be in this position it's a
miracle and I thank my lucky stars and
Richard and Lilly zanuck who had the
faith to give me this wonderful chance
and also most especially to that
forgotten man my director Bruce
Beresford
the caste that was with me which made a
wonderful happy family it was a pleasure
to go to work with them all each day and
to Sam Cohen who takes such good care of
me thank you
the Academy and all of you I am on cloud
nine